hemos visto una campaña polarizada por
una parte de gustavo petro propone un
cambio social y su principal oponente
federico gutiérrez lo acusa de querer
dañar la democracia mientras tanto como
una tercera opción rodolfo hernández ha
subido en las encuestas
todo esto nos muestra un país dividido
como puede el próximo presidente de
colombia gobernar así muy buenas tardes
muchas gracias por la invitación los
resultados del congreso de la república
ya nos dieron un escenario en el cual
sabremos cómo sería esa gobernabilidad
por lo menos dentro del congreso vemos
como gustavo petro tiene apenas una
bancada de 48 senadores y alrededor de
88 representantes a la cámara eso no es
mayoría suficiente para esos grandes
trámites legislativos que se tienen que
hacer en el país en comparación con una
bancada mayoritaria como la tiene
federico gutiérrez con los partidos
tradicionales que lo acompañan situación
totalmente diferente si vemos el caso
del ingeniero rodolfo hernández que
solamente cuenta apenas con dos
representantes a la cámara una
ingobernabilidad absoluta en este
momento si lo vemos en esos términos en
conclusión hoy lo que tendríamos en un
escenario de la vuelta en la cual pasen
como mayores opcionados federico
gutiérrez y gustavo petro es que al
señor petro no lo dejarían gobernar en
el congreso y al señor federico
gutiérrez no lo dejarían gobernar las
calles que seleccionaron que hemos visto
en el último gobierno bueno y cambiamos
de tema porque hace tan solo 20 días la
banda criminal del clan del golfo
paralizó más de 100 municipios de
colombia con su paro armado esto en
respuesta de la extradición de su jefe
dairo antonio úsuga alias otoniel como
impacta esto en la seguridad de las
elecciones y qué tan seguro es votar hoy
especialmente en las regiones rurales
donde ya se presentó un hecho como nos
lo contaba daniel hablando hoy en
colombia vivimos un escenario de miedo
ambiente electoral si se quiere en menos
de 6 meses hemos visto dos palos armados
el primero previo a las elecciones de
congreso por parte de la ln que tuvo
también un gran impacto y más
recientemente el paro armado relacionado
con plan del golfo luego de la
extradición de otoniel más que por una
causa relacionada incluso con el factor
electoral de hecho él ln y parte de las
disidencias hicieron un cese armado
dentro de las elecciones
el golfo no se ha pronunciado pero no se
han visto mayores desmanes incluso parte
de los dos artefactos explosivos que se
registraron esta mañana por parte del
ministerio de defensa estuvieron
relacionados con las disidencias por lo
que habrá sido la muerte gentil duarte
esta semana bueno y si bien todavía la
seguridad no se ha afectado en términos
históricos la violencia si ha aumentado
en los territorios más golpeados por el
conflicto y por el abandono estatal
desde la firma del acuerdo de paz entre
el estado y la extinta guerrilla de las
farc en 2016 al menos 1300 seis líderes
sociales han sido asesinados indígenas
campesinos y la población afro y también
los desmovilizados de las farc son el
principal blanco de ataque sólo en 2022
mataron a 79 líderes sociales además de
21 firmantes del acuerdo de paz hasta la
fecha colombia ha sufrido 44 masacres
únicamente en el departamento del cauca
los grupos armados ilegales han
asesinado a 12 líderes en el último año